get home from this two-day immersive  course on northern and southern Italian  cooking and you are about to go on a  date with Benji yes it was and we had  talked about it all weekend and I drove  you to a grocery store so pregnant I  don't believe I went and no you stayed  inside and you were in the bowl yeah and  you went inside and what was the dish  you made him that night I'm gonna let  you tell it I remember it clears down  lamb chops Mediterranean style lamb  chops some couscous  and  um some Brock broccoli and sauteed  zucchini  did you make him the shallot gold that  night I put shallot gold inside the  couscous  do you see what I'm saying